hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar instrument compliance
for quality system a candid conversation
about IQ o qpq I'm Judy O'Rourke
elaborates and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab Rhodes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific thermo Fisher is a
world leader in serving science whose
mission is to enable customers to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speakers Randall
Albright the global product manager for
compliance and professional services at
Thermo Fisher Scientific and Dean
Rainbolt
the technical applications manager for
the cold storage division at Thermo
Fisher Scientific
Randall Albright is responsible for the
business segments of the qualifications
computer system validation and
analytical validation services for the
applied Biosystems in beat region and
ion torrent instruments his prior
background includes several years as a
US FDA investigator specializing in
medical devices and imports Randall
brings over 25 years of industry
experience in biotechnology and
engineering Dean Rainbolt has over 28
years of pharmaceutical experience and
spent more than twenty one of those
supporting multiple business units these
include development stability corporate
reference standards and analytical
testing labs as well as the bioassay
group in regard to asset management
validation and qualification services he
was the primary audit contact in these
areas in order for other internal
business units and is considered a
process validation expert among his
peers
Randall Albright and Dean Rainbow will
now begin their presentations
welcome everyone to Thermo Fisher
Scientific webinar about instrument and
equipment compliance through a
qualification my name is Randall
Albright and I'm here representing
Thermo Fisher Scientific Life Sciences
Division
and I'm Dean ring representing the
controlled temperature technologies
group within the laboratory products
division
let's quickly review the learning
objectives for this webinar we will
learn where a qualification comes from
we will learn what a qualification is
and what Thermo Fisher Scientific
provides in its IQ oq + PQ from both the
Life Sciences instrumentation and cold
storage equipment we will learn when
qualifications are performed why
qualifications are important and where
they can be applied
a Dean in order for our audience to
fully understand the value of a
qualification I think it's essential to
have a basic idea of what process
validation is now I attended your
wonderful webinar a while back I know
you're an expert in this area can you
give us some perspective
well thanks Randall I'm glad you enjoyed
the auto readiness webinar Hilary
Thompson of the instrument and equipment
service team and I enjoyed working
together to address questions regarding
what things to consider to prepare for
an audit so let's get to it
what is process validation we can break
it into four segments first there is the
process plan which needs to include
information such as what regulations are
to be followed and what industry
standards should be considered next we
have qualification this would include
everything from facility and utility
preparations to completion of equipment
testing third is the validation report
which provides an overview of the entire
validation project the report is
reviewed and signed by the system owner
and quality and last on the list is the
workflow release which is the collection
of documents produced during a
validation project that would include
the appropriate signatures for release
thanks Dean for that overview as Dean
described the qualification of equipment
instrumentation and associated software
is an integral part of process
validation here is the specific code of
federal regulation or CFR section or
process validation but Dean defined
earlier for us this CFR and the
complementary ISO standards applicable
for medical devices
13:45 require that validation
particularly of manufacturing shall be
performed I have highlighted some of the
important language that the guidance
documents help interpret subsection a
calls Outland process validation is
redone where results cannot be fully
verified subsection B calls out more
details of who what and how and when
process evaluation should be done
specifically qualified individuals shall
document all stated requirements with a
process to review evaluate and
revalidate where appropriate note that
despite having explicit elements and
tasks for manufacturers to follow it
does not call out the qualification
mechanism so where do qualifications
come from
it is in the mess da medical revised
quality systems guidance document from
1996 that first officially established
the use of IQ o Q and P Q terminology
for medical devices separate from the
previous medical device GMP regulation
but it is in the 2004 release of global
harmonization task force process
validation guidance document which is an
internationally harmonized document
recognised by both the US fda and ISO
that further clarifies the definition of
IQ o Q and P Q how it is applied and
establishes the qualification as the
industry standard mechanism to document
performance for medical devices
just as a fun fact qualification is not
just an industry standard for medical
devices for example everyone has heard
of Amazon well Amazon qualifies the
conveyance systems in their shipping
warehouses and performs a computer
system validation of the software that
operates those conveyances
for perspective and to better understand
subsection B I have also provided the
FDA quality systems definition of
established for this audience
established being defined as defined
document and implement
moving back into the CFR definitions if
we dig deep into 820 point 70 G it
defines the essentials of what equipment
performance needs to be document as
before I have highlighted the pertinent
language that guidance interpreter
industry again it's not calling out IQ o
Q or P Q mechanism but rather what needs
to be document I have called out the
subsection specific to manufacturer
permits for maintenance inspection and
adjustment of equipment implicit in each
of these is documentation each
manufacturer shall establish and
maintain schedules for the maintenance
of equipment each manufacturer shall
conduct periodic inspections in
accordance with established procedures
then each manufacturer shall ensure that
inherent limitations or allowable
tolerances are boasted on or near
equipment
now that we have established the
industry-standard origin of
qualification from within regulation and
standards for process validation we can
move on to what a qualification is as
most of you will be familiar there are
three components to a qualification
installation operational and performance
notice an additional Chevron below PQ on
the slide here is where Thermo Fisher
Scientific Live scientist group
differentiates its ru low or research
use only and IV D or in vitro diagnostic
DX branded instrument products the PQ is
performed with the DX IV d
instrumentation and the IP v or
instrument performance verification is
performed with the re ro R or research
use only insurance to be clear for our
audience this is strictly Thermo Fisher
Scientific nomenclature to differentiate
our instrumentation and the
qualification services for all intensive
purposes they are equivalent where we
have instrument systems as both DX or
IBD and AR ùl and the standard for
performance is the same the process and
specification for passing will be the
same all three components make up a
qualification protocol we will be
speaking in more detail for each of
these qualification components as well
as the difference between a hardware
product P Q and a workflow process PQ
thanks Randall one thing that I'd like
to add here is that the qualification is
the customer's responsibility and by
that I mean that the customers should
have pre-approved documents to capture
the tasks being completed during the
qualification with cold storage testing
we can provide the temperature mapping
to fulfill the requirement of a
qualification document the customer will
be responsible for the details of the
test such as test duration open door
sample pulse simulation and power off
testing the customer is also responsible
for defining the pass/fail of any
testing that is performed
moving on to the details before
opponent of a qualification is
installation by definition the
installation qualification will
establish with confidence that process
equipment and ancillary systems are
installed the manufacturer's
recommendations
additional sporting details about
installation instructions and test
procedures can be found in Section eight
twenty point one seventy installation
what does Thermo Fisher Scientific
interpret this to mean for the
installation of instrumentation
it means we will verify and document
instruments or equipment against an
order invoices any site requirements
specific to the instrument or equipment
any configuration details of the
instrument or equipment and any specific
installation criteria
it should be noted that the IQ or
installation qualification is not
repeated once the instrument or
equipment is successfully installed
follow along qualifications would be an
au q PQ
now it's also common for companies to
include updating their computerized
maintenance management system or CMS at
this step this ensures that the new
asset is in the system and all
maintenance activities are being tracked
and documented this is also the place
that future scheduled POS can be pre
scheduled so that the instrument will be
maintained in a qualified State
component2 if the qualification is
operational by definition the
operational qualification will establish
with confidence that process equipment
and ancillary systems are capable of
consistently operating within the
manufacturer establish limits and
specification tolerances additional
supporting detail can be found in 820
Point 72 inspection measuring and test
equipment 820 point 80 acceptance
activities and subpart n of eight twenty
point two hundred servicing all in the
Code of Federal Regulations Thermo
Fisher Scientific has broken down the
operational section into effective
subsystems about instruments and
equipment
for example some of the subsystems and
testing are done our internal self-test
Diagnostics thermal testing lamp laser
alignment checks and other optical
calibrations
now in most cases or instances in the
cold storage business a temperature
mapping would be performed this test
would be done with the unit empty and
that's to show that the unit performs is
specified by the manufacturer
the final component of a qualification
is performance qualification or
instrument performance verification
remember Thermo Fisher Scientific uses
PQ for DX or IV D instruments and ipv4
it's are ul instruments by definition
the performance qualification for
instrument performance verification will
establish with confidence that the
process equipment or ancillary systems
are performing to manufacture
recommendations by demonstration with
objective evidence
now this might be a bit confusing for
most common understanding of a PQ or
performance qualification establishes
the limits and specifications for the
entire workflow or process including the
equipment instruments and software
in the case of thermo Fisher Scientific
the instrument hardware qualification p2
component is focused on the workflow of
the instrument hardware as a product P Q
not as the larger workflow or process P
Q that the instrument is being used in
our hardware PQ establishes utility of
the instrument to a standard
independently from its suitability for
use in the total process workflow thus
the thermo Fisher scientific instrument
hardware qualification becomes a
supporting element in the larger process
validation
unfortunately thermo Fisher cannot
perform the process valuation for you
some examples of a hardware PQ or IP D
standard Thermo Fisher Scientific uses
and tensor notation is the RNA speed
plate for the qpcr or quantitative PCR
instruments sequencing or gene scans and
standards for its capillary or cee
electrophoresis instruments control
beads for synthetic controls in our NGS
or next-generation sequencing
and now for cold storage
your mapping is always the best test
method to answer the many PQ question is
required by the customer testing with
the unit with simulated load open door
to simulate sample polls power off
testing for possible future power
failures and different shelf
configuration testing or some of the
common tests that are included in the PQ
if the unit can be used at different
temperatures testing at each possible
setpoint will also be needed
now that we know what a qualification is
we can ask when our qualifications
acquired installation or relocation
should be points of common understanding
however I find out other bullet points
here can be less understood most of the
life sciences instrumentation will have
an annual planned maintenance
recommendation the focus of this is
purely maintenance and to maintain
performance within specifications
examples of this are cleaning of optics
fans thermal blocks and associated
computer maintenance such as
defragmenting after such an activity it
would be recommended to document the
continuing performance of the system as
a requalification similarly we use a
risk-based approach in alignment with
FDA philosophy to make a recommendation
to customers about requalification after
each and every service event the
determination is based on the guidance
language significant to the performance
of the system
let me provide the audience with an
example of how this risk-based
recommendation is applied if a field
service engineer replaces a door hinge
assembly that has nothing to do with how
the instrument operates or generates
data it would not be triggering a
requalification however if the field
service engineer replaces a halogen lamp
which would be changing the fluorescent
intensity as well as the filter and dye
calibration on the instrument this would
have an impact on the data thus would
generate a requalification beam are
there any equipment very qualification
variations from my instrument based
example
sure let me briefly touch on as found
testing versus post maintenance testing
the strategy for cold storage
qualification timing is very similar to
the life sciences approach there is one
additional time point that I've seen
added to the qualification strategy with
some pharmaceutical companies this
qualification which is usually referred
to as an as found test is simply a
temperature mapping exercise with the
existing sample load that is performed
before certain TM work is started
testing unit prior to the p.m. serves to
close the bracket so to speak of data
from the last qualification until before
the p.m. that we will be performed by
bracketing this data it will
considerably shortly or eliminate the
risk of a long investigation of samples
for an equipment failure that may have
been caused during the p.m. after the
p.m. work has been completed adjustments
can be made to dial in the unit so the
operator sort will operate at its peak
performance without any risk once the
unit is dialed in post testing is done
so that the unit can be released for use
now please keep in mind that there are
only a few situations that have wanted
this as found testing but it is a viable
option
why are qualifications important
vacations are important as documented
evidence of performance over time as we
have established in the previous slide
qualifications are periodic and ongoing
necessity qualification support quality
management systems process validation
mitigate risk of results to provide
sample integrity and provide evidence of
suitability for use or intended use
now I want to pause here I believe this
is the most overlooked concept when it
comes to understanding the qualification
I believe Dean will agree
what I typically see is customers
looking at the price of the service
trying to mitigate their operating costs
however let me share an FDA experience
with you all that I think is a perfect
case study especially for those in ldt
and IVD environments
I was designed the investigation of a
for-cause action of a medical device
manufacturer based on an MDR or medical
device reportable event the MDR reported
was our clinical lab the supplied
results to a hospital where a patient
was injured to a prescription of an
incorrect therapeutic because the
clinical lab maintained excellent device
history records with qualifications
sample processing and operator use an
investigation was quickly able to narrow
down the potential impact between the
medical device manufacturer the clinic
and the political lab established with
instrument what operator and what sample
was in question using the device history
file we segregated the sample
populations in question process to one
instrument and the possible time frame
with a potential deviation that caused
the injury they're viewing the
qualification that in the device history
file the lab showed that the last
qualification instrument was still in
specification a subsequent qualification
of the instrument performed during the
investigation showed it was still in
specification thus ruling out the
instrument and the samples process
adjacent and subsequently the sample in
question the investigation ultimately
concluded with sample contamination as a
cause for the missed result
but for the good laboratory and
documentation practices and consistent
instrument qualifications in the devices
profile the investigation was able to
with assistance from the manufacturer
and operators to quickly eliminate and
mitigate the impact of clinical
operations other patients and resolved
root cause Nadine I know you've had
similar experiences from another
perspective do you have another story to
share
sure now let's just see if I can stick
to one example here because it's very
common for businesses to consider
cutting qualification and service
budgets first to save money that
decision is usually made by folks
unfamiliar with the importance of
maintaining equipment a qualified state
so in this case we were performing an
internal audit of a customer complaint
for a product that had been on the
market for several years the audit was
focused on the organization of stores
marketed products to be used as a
reference standard if needed
now storage of these reference standards
in the proper condition it's critical
and tightly monitored as the loss of
product reference could lead to a
product recall and nobody wants a recall
if it's not a drug quality related
recall now during the audit report all
of the documentation needed to show that
the unit was running within a qualified
state then included the initial IQ ODU
and PG documents it also included the
relevant maintenance records and the
last qualification documentation prior
to the time that the samples were pulled
and tested
this ensured that sample safety had been
maintained and there was no reason to
dispute the sample test results at this
level this group had fulfilled its
commitment to sample safety and
equipment integrity without a
well-thought-out qualification strategy
including proper implementation this
could have gone a whole other direction
the purchase of the right equipment is
the first step to success maintaining
that equipment in a qualified state
ensures ongoing success
so let's talk about
a validation in qualification myths myth
one validation of a process equipment or
instruments has only done once no
revalidation is required for process
changes reference 21 CFR a 20 70 b3
changes to equipment or instrument or
specification changes would trigger
re-evaluation Rhian validations should
be performed of performance of equipment
or instruments documented in the
qualifications show any deviations or
negative trends revalidation should be
performed if there are process failures
or kappa related activities
on the ms2 validation is only necessary
for process where subsequent
verification is possible validation
should be considered even if your
process includes 100% verification 100%
verification is not necessarily 100%
effective in a process myth number three
invalidation is burdensome yes
validation can be burdensome and costly
but planning is key to mitigation at
this point validation is also an
investment in the process equipment
instrumentation and personnel it helps
you understand the controls necessary to
reduce variability reducing variability
reduces risk to results and products
from the process and reduces operational
costs a well-planned process validation
improves customer satisfaction and
confidence
myth for my field service report or plan
maintenance report is sufficient to
document performance
no to understand why service report or
maintenance protocol cannot stand in for
a qualification is because of the
intention of the document this is how a
potential investigator will establish
the utility of the documentation for
viewing provided by a firm the intent of
a service report is to document the
scope of service event required a
maintenance protocol intentions to
document the manufacturer's recommended
maintenance activity has been performed
only a qualification is the industry
accepted mechanism to document
performance as called out in the global
harmonization Task Force also the
international medical device regulators
form and FDA medical device quality
systems or regulations guidance
documents we spoke about in the
beginning of the webinar
where are qualifications applicable here
is my attempt to align some of the
applicable standards and regulations to
customer segments that should consider
process validation and qualification
services
for Thermo Fisher Scientific as a
manufacturer we have been looking at
party 20 the iso 9001 and 1345
for some of you in the audience your
interests mail line with CLIA cap and
the ISO fifteen one eight nine but
understand these are only some of the
more globally accepted markets and
qualifications there will be many local
regional or international governmental
entities which will also support the use
of a qualification to document
performance of equipment or
instrumentation as part of a workflow we
recommend using the guidance documents
from the global harmonization task force
international medical device regulator
form and the Food and Drug
Administration as reference starting
points
because science can't wait on
non-compliance D and I would like to
circle back to the webinar learning
objectives we have learned about process
validation and the origin of a
qualification as the industry standard
what a qualification is and what Thermo
Fisher Scientific provides in its IQ Oh
Q and P Q when qualifications are
performed why qualifications are
important and where qualifications can
be applied
you
you
Thermo Fisher Scientific is very proud
of our mission providing compliance and
qualification Services is one of many
ways Thermo Fisher Scientific which
supports you our customer your
laboratory processes and quality systems
to make the world healthier cleaner and
safer
for more information about Thermo Fisher
Scientific qualifications of
instrumentation equipment but other
compliance-related products we urge you
to reach out and contact us you can
visit our web page or email us for
additional details or call us to have a
conversation with one of our specialists
we will be happy to address any
follow-up questions through our teams
you
on behalf of myself Randall Albright
representing Thermo Fisher Scientific
Life Sciences
a team rainbow representing the
controlled temperatures Technologies
group within the laboratory products
division
we appreciate your attendance in our
qualification webinar
Thank You Randall and Dean for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask question
and click on the send button
Randall Albright and Dean Rainbolt will
answer as many questions as time permits
the first question is what are the risks
if I create or do the qualification
myself
I can answer that one the risk of a
customer developed protocol is will it
be adequate to document performance of
the medical device or system being
disconnected from the design process
typically leads to a customer protocol
skipping operational areas that would
have been captured by the manufacturer
thank you next question is how much time
can I save by having the manufacturer of
record perform the qualification versus
using in-house resources
I don't have any specific statistics on
this but the length of time to develop a
qualification protocol would be
dependent on the complexity of the
system workflow and the risk tolerance
of the workflow having a manufacturer
qualified their instrumentation
equipment allows quality systems to
focus on the risk tolerance of the
workflow making the equipment
qualification or instrument
qualification more plug-and-play to the
validation process
thank you next one is how often should I
reek wallah fie an instrument
this is a risk determination by the
manufacturers recommendation and the
risk tolerance of the workflow
Thermo Fisher Scientific uses that risk
based determination to make a
recommendation to reek wala Phi at
minimum for the life sciences group
instrumentation we would recommend after
a planned maintenance or after a
critical maintenance that is significant
to the performance of the system
thanks to that looks like we have time
for one more question how long does it
take thermo Fisher to perform their
qualification services
for the life sciences instrumentation it
depends on the type of instrument but
typically between half a day and two and
a half days of on-site time with a field
service engineer or application
scientists depending on the application
and also it depends on what the customer
needs which is usually a minimum of one
24 hour test up to several days of
temperature mapping to fulfill the
requirements of an o2 PQ and that would
be in the cold storage area
well I would like to once again thank
Randall Albright and Dean Rainbolt for
their presentations and I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
we'll be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast and until next time
goodbye